hey this is a kind of interesting so
some of you may know that I've been
listening to the Howard Stern Show for
more than 20 years when I used to when I
first got my license in high school even
before then I would in the car listen to
Howard Stern when he was on terrestrial
radio he's of course now on sirius XM
radio and one of howard stern's
producers his name brent Hatley and he
is not only a producer for the Howard
Stern Show but he also follows the David
Pakman show Brent and I have been in
touch for like a year or two online and
I was listening to the Howard Stern Show
earlier this week and they were talking
about how brent has been fainting in
certain situations and then recovering
pretty quickly and as I was listening to
it the circumstances sounded pretty
similar to what I've experienced in my
life I had some fainting incidents as a
kid and then just a couple of years ago
our audience might remember that I
actually fainted on a plane coming back
from Italy and it sounded what I
experienced sounded very similar to what
Brent had been experiencing and I had a
cardiology workup to make sure that my
heart was okay and it was chalked up to
what are called vasovagal syncope s that
have usually been a combination of
having alcohol and coffee in close
proximity to each other at high
elevation or on a plane which is
pressurized too depending on the plane
somewhere between five and eight
thousand feet of elevation and so I've
stopped doing that and I've been okay
since and I told Brent this is what it
sounds like and eventually this got me a
mansion on the Howard Stern Show and
it's sort of weird because I a medical
advice I was telling Brent this is how I
experienced it and it was very funny so
tune in and to hear Brent say that David
Pakman mentioned that it sounds like
vasovagal syncope take a listen to this
Brent do you ever get a deja vu type of
feeling before you pass out that's
evidently one of the feelings if you
have Basso baggo psychopaths Howard yeah
I think the vasa vagal is the one that
Brent thinks he may have that's what a
Cornel told him well the best advice I
saw out of all the email Brent should
see a cardiologist is it a full workup
right
I had a pacemaker put in at the age of
37 it was due to my heart not beating
for 12 to 16 seconds at a time my
condition is called complete heart block
the electrical signals
would not pass through my heart to cause
the muscle to pump yeah I like you know
that this listener says any doctor would
any good doctor would refer Brent to a
neurologist and a cardiologist full
workup after passing out he kept saying
he's fit so they aren't worried about
his heart I call [ __ ] heart issues
have nothing to do with fitness yeah I
don't even think that Brent really went
to a doctor yeah I don't know that this
person who said smoke all the pot you
want
he found a dr. feelgood yeah I think
Brent is a hypochondriac well I think if
he's passing out I don't that's proof
that something could be wrong this guy
goes Brenda's a hypochondriac all those
fainting episodes are fake brent is
going through a full-on midlife crisis
it's obvious he's gonna faint it
wouldn't be so bad if it happened while
he was on the air boy a lot of medical
information I did make an appointment
with a cardiologist I thought I talked
to one yesterday yes and he's gonna see
me in early July he's gonna get me in so
okay thank you to the show for that
because yes because that got me into a
really good doctor here in Manhattan oh
you know you know a full workup is a
good idea pal that's what that's what he
said he said we're gonna do a full
workup to make sure there's no serious
heart issues yes it sounds like a
cardiovascular issue too yes well look
you know by the way Brent refuses to
quit weed for three months in fact there
was a post-show interview yesterday that
I heard and can made me a little sad
Brent when I heard this let me play it
for everyone so are you gonna take
Howard's advice no why I got stuff
coming up that I want to do and I you
know what I'd rather have a medical
issue than deal with the world why don't
you want to deal with the world you just
take a look around the world is an awful
depressing horrible place to deal with
so you know marijuana has that chemical
in it called it I've lived a good life
so if this is if I'm not long for this
world then fine but if not I'm just I
just do not want to deal with reality
you know a brother oh I have found that
a lot of people who say hey you know and
I've lived long enough if that's the way
it is that's the way it and then as soon
as they get diagnosed with something the
first ones go I don't want to die you
know what I mean you don't want to
no I really don't but I do actually feel
a lot better yesterday after talking to
you know one of the guys that works in
my office not surely his wife has
vasovagal and she talked to me yesterday
which got me to talk to a cardiologist
there's a radio guy I know David Pakman
sent me a DM and said that he has basal
vagal right and it sounds like the same
thing so this cardiologist said let's do
a full workup let's make sure that's
what are you talking pal so there it is
I guess I don't even know that there's
that much more to say about it it's
interesting hopefully Brent gets good
news from his cardiologist it is much
better to have vasovagal incidents or a
tendency to them than to have some kind
of more serious heart issue and when I
had to wear this 30-day heart monitor
which coincided with when I had to fly
back and forth from Las Vegas to this
conference that I go to with other
progressive media hosts and go through
airport security with this heart monitor
it was a mess but my real concern was I
hope that I'm not having this fainting
issue because my heart is stopping for a
few seconds altogether and I got a clean
bill of health and was told don't drink
alcohol and coffee when you're at
elevation and that's basically been it
knock on wood since then and hopefully
Brent gets the same same good news if
you love learning new things you
probably want to check this out the
david pakman show today is sponsored by
Skillshare and we're giving you two
entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy to use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath
this video two months of learning
something that's totally new to you
something you want to get better at
something you already love or you can
get ahead in your career by learning new
skills that will help you at your job
I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video